attention elle décor mais surtout elle
vend tout on la surnomme la valérie
damidot de magny les hameaux
catherine d'or qu'elle anime depuis peu
les ventes aux enchères sur le web du
matériel déclassé de la ville et
aujourd'hui elle fait un heureux
pour 150 euros via le site web enchères
ce responsable associatif repart avec
une caméra vintage en parfait état
joindre l'utile à l'agréable avec une
pointe de nostalgie césar des matériels
ça serait plus et j'en ai il ya déjà
plus de 20 ans et puis voilà et là je
suis sûreté sur l'occasion quand j'ai vu
ça sur les yeux bruns cher et lg à un
chéri j'ai un shérif et voilà me mauger
les décorer et détourner l' usage
d'origine de tous les objets qu'elle
conçoit la taille tel est l'objectif de
catherine qui ne manque pas d'idées
elle cherche par exemple à donner une
seconde vie à ce cadastre inadaptée
acheté pour 22 mille euros il ya plus de
dix ans la mairie le propose aujourd'hui
pour dix fois moins j'aime bien côté
déco il ya plein de choses qui peuvent
servir de question d tous cas
industriels il ya plein de choses qui
font un peu industriels des couleurs tu
mini-quad mobilier scolaire broyeur à
végétaux ou anciennes saleuses
particuliers et pme ils trouvent leur
compte près de 3000 euros ont déjà été
récoltés ils seront réinjectés dans le
budget de la commune nous avons un
nouveau local qui va être équipée pour
les jeunes cap'ados bon bain sans doute
qu'une partie servira peut être
récupérée locale catherine d'or qu'elle
consacre deux jours par mois à animer et
à faire l'inventaire de ses ventes grâce
à sa tablette et à une application
dédiée
elle parcourt la commune à la recherche
de matériel à déclasser une vocation
sociale et
viviane et les objets qu'on vend
utilitaire qui rendent service il ya des
objets qui vont des pannes et des
personnes pour pas les moyens de
s'acheter cet objet l'a9 aux autres
j'espère sur trouver le trésor
alors c'est jamais une méthode moderne
de se séparer du matériel inutilisé et
de libérer de l'espace
d'autres communes s'y mettent comme
billancourt qui a lancé ces enchères sur
le web l'an dernier